Some consider Thomas Edison one
of the greatest inventors ever.
Edison was photographed next to
a lightbulb so often that people
came to believe he invented it. But he didn’t.
Several inventors had demonstrated
various versions of incandescent
lights before Edison patented the first
commercially successful lightbulb.
Edison never crafted something out of nothing.
His genius lay in his ability
to craft something better.
To perfect what was already available.
His critics say his only real invention was
taking credit for the inventions of others.
So, was he America’s greatest
inventor or…was Edison a thief?
You decide.
Edison’s life changed when he was 15 years old.
One day, when he saw a station official’s young
son playing by the tracks in the path of an
oncoming train, Edison rescued two-year-old
Jimmie Mackenzie before a train crushed him.
The boy’s father was deeply grateful and taught
Edison how to operate Morse code on a telegraph
machine. This was not easy to do; operators had
to quickly send out signals in dots and dashes,
which were converted into letters
that made up words and phrases.
Edison began working full-time as
a telegraph operator in Michigan,
where he grew up, and later
traveled around America,
working at different offices for years.
(Started at telegraph office in Port Huron)
He was able to do this even
though he was moderately deaf.
He then decided to devote
himself to a life as an inventor.
Well, actually, he mainly improved
upon what was already invented.
In 1874, he developed an advanced version of a
telegraph machine that could send and receive
four telegraph messages simultaneously
on a single wire - two in each direction.
His quadruplex telegraph machine enabled
his former employer Western Union to save
money because the company could now send more
messages without having to build new lines.
Western Union purchased the rights
to the invention for $10,000, around
$260,000 in value today.
Edison used the money to build his great
laboratory at Menlo Park, New Jersey.
He began by perfecting the telephone there.
By 1876, Alexander Graham Bell had found a way to
transmit human voices over wires.
The telephone was revolutionary.
Western Union commissioned Edison
to improve upon Bell’s invention,
to make it practical, and so Edison
worked on a telephone transmitter.
While working to perfect the phone, he
also tried to record the human voice.
The phonograph put Edison on the map - giving
him the nickname the “Wizard of Menlo Park”.
He began to expand his factory…and
his appetite for other inventions.
His big breakthrough came when he created
a successful incandescent lightbulb.
As I mentioned earlier, others had
already been making light bulbs.
British inventor Joseph Swan obtained the
first patent for a light bulb in Britain
two years before Edison patented the lightbulb.
https://patents.google.com/patent/US205144A/en
- electric lamp Sawyer and Man
Meanwhile, in America, William Sawyer and
Albon Man had received a U.S. patent
for the incandescent lamp in 1878.
So what did Edison do? He improved
the bulb. Previous ones had only been
able to work for merely a few minutes at a time.
By October 1879, Edison had an “aha” moment.
His bulb with a carbonized filament
burned continuously for 14.5 hours.
But that still wasn’t good enough for him.
He and his assistant tested thousands
of plant materials and finally came
up with a filament made from bamboo
that could last up to 1,200 hours.
In 1880, Edison received a historic patent
for an improvement to electric lamps.
It’s been debated whether Edison’s patent
infringed on Sawyer and Man’s previous patent.
Eventually, Edison’s American lighting company
merged with the Thomson-Houston Electric Company -
which made incandescent bulbs under the Sawyer-Man
patent. Together, they formed General Electric.
On New Year’s Eve, 1879, Edison
lit up New York’s Christie Street,
marking the dawn of the electric age.
This was at a time when the world
still relied on candlesticks.
He then began to mass produce and sell them.
But he didn’t stop with just improving the bulb.
Edison then began working on building a system to
carry electricity so people
could use his light bulbs.
In 1882, he set up a large generator plant
on Pearl Street in lower Manhattan
and lit the street with electricity.
He became rich and famous.
And…ruthless.
Like when he tried to discredit
a rival form of electricity.
Edison’s generating system used
direct current, which has its flaws.
DC travels through a power line in one
direction at a constant voltage but can
only go up to a mile or so before losing power, so
a generating plant was required every few blocks.
He hired a young engineer to
improve upon his DC generators.
But Nikola Tesla came up with a
better solution: alternating current.
AC periodically changes direction
and can also vary its voltage. It
can travel hundreds of miles without losing power.
Yet when Tesla tried to convince
Edison of the advantages of AC,
his boss wasn’t having any of it.
Edison didn’t want to lose the
royalties he earned from his DC patents.
Tesla’s AC system caught the attention of American
industrialist George Westinghouse
who bought up Tesla’s patents.
AC generators were spreading fast across the
country - faster than Edison’s DC system.
So in order to discredit his rivals’ AC
system, Edison devised an ugly strategy.
He gave boys who lived around his New Jersey lab
25 cents for every stray dog they brought him
and organized public electrocutions of
these dogs with AC.
Edison took every opportunity to question
the safety of Tesla’s AC system, declaring:
"Just as certain as death, Westinghouse will kill
a customer within six months after
he puts in a system of any size."
Edison secretly funded the first electric chair,
which used AC - despite publicly
denouncing capital punishment.
The state of New York had commissioned his
former assistant Harold Brown to build the chair.
Brown pushed to have it powered by AC
using a Westinghouse generator that he
surreptitiously secured through another company.
But his schemes didn’t work; AC would go on
to power the world, much to Edison’s dismay.
Yet, Edison was more famous than
Tesla and certainly a lot wealthier.
Tesla died very poor - I’ve done
a series of videos on what led
to Tesla’s tragic demise which
I’ll link to in my description.
Edison patented a whopping 1,093
inventions in his lifetime!
He managed thousands of skilled scientists,
machinists, and designers who researched,
developed, and manufactured new technologies.
So, where did Edison’s real genius lie?
As Graham Moore writes in his novel The Last Days
of Night about the feud between
Edison and Westinghouse and Tesla:
“His genius was not in inventing; rather, it
was in inventing a system of invention. Dozens
of researchers and engineers and developmental
tinkerers labored beneath Edison in a carefully
constructed hierarchical organization
that he founded and oversaw.”
In order words, Thomas Edison
was not a genius inventor or a
thief but a savvy businessman who
had a knack for managing people.
It was his shrewdness as a manager that
allowed him to turn laboratory discoveries into
technological marvels in the marketplace even if
many of the original ideas came from someone else.
Regardless of how you feel about Thomas Edison,
his contributions have
undoubtedly improved our lives.
Whether you’re a fan of him or
Nikola Tesla - what they both
had in common was firm grasp of math and science.
If you’d like to improve your STEM skills -
to invent the next great thing or simply to
better understand the world, Brilliant is
a website and app where you can learn math,
science, and computer science interactively.
I know my viewers particularly love their
Scientific Thinking course. In this exercise,
you have to make the bridge as rigid as
possible with as few beams as possible.
Another course popular with my
viewers is their Pre-Algebra course,
where you can strengthen your math skills in
a fun way where it doesn’t feel like learning.
If you ever get stuck, you can click the
explanation to see where you went wrong.
Brilliant is great for both those who are in
school and also if you’re already working.
I personally use Brilliant myself to
help improve my critical thinking skills.
You can dedicate a few minutes a
day to improving your STEM skills
by relearning the basics of having
fun with their more advanced courses.
And it’s FREE for you to sign up with the custom
link in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who sign up with
my link will get 20% Brilliant’s annual
premium membership, which gives you unlimited
access to the hundreds of courses they offer.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.